everyone in the whole place is on their
feet a tremendous display of
sportsmanship hi I'm Jack McBrayer and
here are some videos but I like to walk
so I do have to admit that I've always
been a fan of commercials and I know
that sounds ridiculous but I like
commercials the first one I'm gonna tell
you about is Oreo Canada wonderful the
group that sings it is al city and it's
really sweet
it's about sharing Oreos and how it
could change people's life it would
become wonderful to you guys
I like the music I like the animation
it's a good commercial
[Music]
another commercial that I like is a
coca-cola commercial Atlanta
and one of the Super Bowl commercials
and it supposedly is captured images
from surveillance cameras all over
[Music]
showed people be nice to each other and
helping each other and sharing a coke
sold
[Music]
another commercial I like is Heineken
premium light and the campaign was
shared the good it's got a great song
it's this guy Chris Knox
ages
it's a good commercial I'm starting to
see a theme here with all my commercials
it's all about like
[Music]
and the last commercial that I like it's
David
it's 2001 sprite commercial I don't know
what the theme was but enter this girl
at the very end of the commercial that
makes me laugh every time I watch it
and that's still clutter to this day oh
girl you want to get together later
contagious
now if you're also wondering I always
love looking up surprise military
homecomings seven-year-old hailey
McGregor was just finishing a
cheerleading routine look what she heard
she heard her father's name announced
over the stadium loudspeaker she's got
her pom-poms around and she sees daddy
they both really start crying but
nervous the whole night I could die this
year there's a good way to see her I
love seeing when deaf people get a
surgery so they can hear for the first
time can you hear me and you hear your
voice you'll get used to all of it and
oh when athletes get helped by the
opposing team it's sweet you guys check
it out you'll feel better about the
world art McMath cramping up in the legs
very obviously has gone to the track a
couple times and she's gonna get help to
cross to finish his standing ovation
here in Columbus how does that feel to
end the race on that kind of note um I
wasn't really paid attention to the
crowd as much I just kind of paying
attention to the girl that I mean she
needed help and I just want to help her
get across the line because she deserved
it I mean she worked this hard to get
here so all right well thanks for
watching I'm Jack McBrayer now you know
too much about me